willkommen zur heutigen Vorlesung wir
werden zu Beginn noch mal ein Blick auf
das begriffsnetz Werfen das kennen Sie
sicherlich mittlerweile schon auswendig
aber es schadet nicht auch zu
Vorbereitung auf die Klausur mal an
irgendeinem Ort zu beginnen im Begriff
Netz also nicht immer von der Person
sondern sie können das begriffsnetz auch
mehr oder weniger von der anderen
Richtung von unten nach oben können Sie
das mal durchlaufen das können sie gerne
mal über die Feiertage machen ich spule
einfach ein bisschen vor das kennen sie
alles schon
und
letzte Sitzung hat mir ein bisschen was
zum Thema determination Notwendigkeit
und Indifferenz gesagt dann mache ich
oben rechts dann nachher auf Youtube den
Link dazu rein zu dieser Sitzung und
jetzt kommt auch was neues dazu
jetzt kommt das Thema Normativität neu
auf das begriffsnetz das ist ein
weiterer wichtiger Knoten Knotenpunkt
ich habe ihn jetzt hier unter
instrumentelle und kategorische
imperative genommen warum das kann man
sich nach überlegen imperative sind ja
Befehle oder Formens und da steht
natürlich schon die Normativität drin da
wo etwas befohlen wird wo etwas gesollt
wird ob es jetzt bedingt gesollt wird
als hypothetische Imperativ also wenn du
den Konstanz Marathon Halbmarathon in
einer Stunde laufen möchtest dann musst
du jetzt schon anfangen zu trainieren
und so weiter und so fort dieses müssen
drücken nochmal Aktivität aus aber
natürlich nur wenn die Bedingung gegeben
ist dass ich überhaupt den Konstanz
Halbmarathon in einer Stunde Rennen
möchte ja kann ja sein ich möchte zwei
Stunden Rennen oder in 3 Stunden oder
muss ich was anderes machen es hängt
also immer davon ab was ich will was
jetzt weg ist und danach richtet sich
dann die Normativität oder das Gebot
könnte man sagen nach der
instrumentellen Vernunft aber es gibt
natürlich noch die moralischen
kategorischen imperative und die sind
nicht bedingt das heißt die gelten
unbedingt die gelten für alle
möglichen Situationen nicht nur wenn ich
eineinhalb Marathon Rennen möchte und
jetzt habe ich jemand Unterschieden es
gibt nicht moralische Normativität das
ist zum Beispiel juristische
programmativität wenn davon irgendeinem
sollen die Rede ist in juristischen
Kontexten mit Gesetzen sie wissen nicht
in allen Ländern gelten dieselben
Gesetze die dieselben Regeln das heißt
juristische Normativität wenn man
überhaupt so davon sprechen möchte
juristische Gesetze die sind natürlich
auch
irgendwie in einer Nähe zu den
instrumentellen hypothetischen
imperativen nicht genau aber sie sind
nicht so absolut weil je nach Situation
es fängt ja schon an mit der
maskenpflicht sowas wie Pflicht wenn sie
in der Schweiz
ohne Maske fahren dann ist es völlig
okay wenn sie aber dann noch zumindest
im Deutschen in der Deutschen Bahn keine
Maske aufhaben dann kommt die schaffen
könnte kommen und könnte sagen sie
müssen eine Maske tragen und wenn sie
dann fragen warum aber in der Schweiz
muss ich doch nicht dann werden die ihn
entgegen nur das ist nun mal die
Gesetzes die Frage hier das ist
gesetzlich geboten wenn man sagt das ist
geboten dann bezieht man sich auf eine
Form von Normativität aber ich möchte
natürlich noch eine andere Form von
Normativität davon unterscheiden sie
ahnen es schon das ist die moralische
Normativität die gilt nicht irgendwie in
der Deutschen Bahn oder nur oder der
Schweizer Bahn nicht oder so sind die
gilt überall wo wir sind die gilt sogar
auf dem Mars oder dem der Venus wenn man
da überhaupt als Mensch unterwegs sein
könnte und moralische Normativität ist
in ihrem Anspruch häufig sogar so extrem
und was heißt extrem so universell ist
vielleicht besser jetzt das viele
TheoretikerInnen und Theoretiker sagen
wenn wir moralische Normativität
begründen wollen dann darf die nicht nur
für Menschen Geld das wieder das
geldungsproblem weil da könnte man ja
sagen
aber wenn es jetzt noch andere Personen
außer Menschen gibt sag mal intelligente
marsianerinnen und Marsianer die sind
vielleicht sogar noch intelligenter als
wir im offenen Haus gibt es
wahrscheinlich kein intelligenten
Lebensform aber es ist doch prinzipiell
nicht ausgeschlossen das ist irgendwo im
großen Universum
erdähnliche Planeten gibt es gibt das
wissen wir auf den vielleicht
intelligente Lebensform beheimatet sind
zumindest ist es nicht auszuschließen es
ist auch möglich dass es mal vielleicht
welche gegeben hat die jetzt aber
ausgestorben sind oder dass es in ferner
Zukunft mal welche geben wird auf
Planeten die nicht Erde heißen und wenn
man jetzt eine sehr verbindliche Moral
entwickeln würde dann würde man sagen
sofern es intelligente Lebewesen sind
was Intelligenz ist Rationalität müssen
wir auch noch mal ein bisschen klären
wir haben schon eine Sitzung dazu
gemacht mache ich auch oben rechts an
den Link rein zu der Sitzung über
Rationalität
jedenfalls müssten diese lebe mit Kant
gesprochen empfänglich sein für
kategorische imperative also die für die
dürften kategorische moralische Gebote
keine Überforderung bedeuten sind die
müssten den Sinn den tieferen Sinn von
moralischen geboten verstehen können
wenn sie das könnte dann würde für sie
auch diese Moral gelten jetzt habe ich
hier natürlich noch eine weitere Form
von Normativität angeführt nämlich der
ästhetischen an Normativität man kann
sich in ganz verschiedenen Bereichen
Normativität denken
sie können sich schon mal überlegen was
ist für eine Art von Normativität sein
könnte wenn es um die ästhetische
Normativität geht sie ahnen ist schon es
geht um das was schön ist auch Schönheit
ist schwach normativ könnte sein schön
und hässlich das sind nicht nur
beschreibende Eigenschaften sondern
damit geht häufig auch eine Wertung
einher ne aber sie merken was schön und
was hässlich ist das ist auch nicht so
ganz klar über Geschmack lässt sich
bekanntlich Streit aber darüber werden
heute auch noch ein bisschen diskutieren
also damit will ich nur sagen wir sind
jetzt hier weiter gekommen im Bereich
der Normativität und sie ahnen schon was
hier in diesem freien Eck hier unten
noch unterkommt da kommen alle im
weitesten Sinne moralphilosophischen
Fragestellung unter ich habe deswegen
hier nur so ein kleines Eckchen am Rand
hier
frei gehalten hier unten rechts weil ich
einfach nicht in Konflikt mit auch in
diesem Semester stattfinden Vorlesung
kommen möchte die dezidiert dem Thema
Moralphilosophie gewidmet sind deswegen
werde ich auf den Begriff Netz hier nur
im Kontext die Handlungstheorie der
praktischen Philosophie noch einen Raum
eröffnen für Fragestellungen die jetzt
auch mit der Moralphilosophie in eine
Beziehung treten ja jetzt machen wir
immer ermöglicht haben Sie die
Möglichkeit Fragen zu stellen und dann
geht es weiter im Programm ja wir machen
jetzt weiter mit dem heutigen Thema was
im Grunde genommen auch schon der
letzten Sitzung behandelt wurde da ging
es um das Thema moralische Normativität
in moralisch habe ich jetzt in Klammern
gemacht weil wie sie bereits gesehen
haben es gibt auch noch andere Formen
von Normativität manchmal sagt man das
sind dann schwach normative Phänomene
also Normativität von Norma lateinisch
irgendwie wie häufig hier Richtschnur
Maßstab Regel Vorschrift rechter Winkel
da sehen sie schon das ist übertragen
also Normativität im Baugewerbe bedeutet
dass man schön den rechten Winkel
einhält ja das also das Haus nicht hier
plötzlich mal mit 87 grad irgendwie
errichtet wird und dann neigt sich die
Wand da hier vielleicht in diesem
Hörsaal könnte das sein deswegen wird er
ja auch nächsten Semester renoviert also
aber es gibt natürlich dann konkreten
moralischen Normativität aufgeben heute
ein politische juristische ästhetische
das bedeutet es geht um Geltung und
Verbindlichkeit Geltung und
Verbindlichkeit erkennen sie darin dass
an sie ein Anspruch gestellt wird oder
dass sie auf sich dass sie ein Befehl
dass sie Adressaten oder Adressat von
Befehlen von Hinweisen sind häufig auch
mit einer gewissen macht verbunden also
das heißt wenn man sich gegen die
Normativität richtet dann muss man
häufig mit Konsequenzen
rechnen wie zum Beispiel in der Bahn
wenn man keine Maske trägt man kann sie
jetzt natürlich über den Sinn der Masken
treffen streiten deswegen ist es bei
Masken ja auch nicht so sehr im
moralische Normativität sind ihre
politische oder juristische Normativität
die eben abhängig von der jeweiligen
Gesetzeslage ist
Normativität können sich ganz leicht
merken die betrifft den Bereich des
zollens und deswegen sage ich jetzt
sollens weil es gibt auch den Bereich
des Seins was ist es gibt den Bereich wo
sie sagen können das ist so und so und
so und es gibt den Bereich des Holz
natürlich kann man auch vom Bereich des
sollen sagens der Bereich des Sollens
ist so und so und so ich soll nämlich
das und das tun also ist das natürlich
auch so aber da wird natürlich eine
Geltung betont die im Bereich des Seins
so nicht zu finden ist also sein und
sollen die Begriffe müssen wir genau
auseinanderhalten und so wie kann ich
jetzt schon sagen in der nächsten und
letzten Sitzung in diesem Sinne dieser
diesem Jahr werden wir uns mit diesem
Verhältnis von sein und sollen ganz
intensiv befassen moralische
Normativität betrifft jetzt die Frage
was soll ich tun
und zwar generellen allen Situationen
und nicht nur wenn ich den Konstanz
Halbmarathon in einer Stunde laufen
möchte ja wenn ich mit diese Frage
stelle dann sie erinnern sich dann
kommen wieder die hypothetischen
imperative dann kommt der Befehl der
bedingte Imperativ ja du solltest jetzt
anfangen täglich so und so viel
Kilometer zu rennen du solltest deine
Ernährung umstellen du solltest
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
Krafttraining machen und du solltest
jetzt einfach mal so die sind diesen
Plan folgen das ist instrumentelle von
uns hypothetische imperative moralische
Normativität betrifft die Frage was soll
ich schlechthin tun was soll ich
grundsätzlich tun nicht nur in Konstanz
wenn ich laufe lustig bin sondern in
allen Lebenslagen das ist diese Frage
und diese Frage was soll ich tun
vielleicht wissen Sie wer die gestellt
hat die hat niemand geringeres als
Immanuel kann aufgeworfen er hat die
drei Fragen oder sogar vier Fragen
aufgeworfen ja was kann ich wissen
was soll ich tun was darf ich hoffen und
was ist der Mensch und alle diese Fragen
betreffen eine philosophische Disziplin
die Frage was kann ich wissen betrifft
die Erkenntnistheorie oder vielleicht
die theoretische Philosophie die Frage
was soll ich tun betrifft die
oralphilosophie oder vielleicht auch die
praktische Philosophie und so weiter und
so fort da gibt's die
Religionsphilosophie und dann noch die
andere Politologie was ist der Mensch
und die politische Normativität oder
juristische Normativität betrifft die
Frage wie soll ich in bestimmten
sozialen verbünden Handeln ja welche
Regeln gibt welche Gesetzesgrundlagen
gibt es die ästhetische Normativität
bedeutet oder drückt aus was ist schön
welche Eigenschaften muss etwas besitzen
damit es halt schön Geld gelten kann
also immer wenn sie solche Wörter wie
Geld haben Geltung beanspruchen dann
wissen Sie der handelt sich schon um
eine schwache oder starke vor mir
nachdem von Normativität und über
Ästhetik da sehen sie da kann man
treffen und
ästhetische Normativität wenn man
überhaupt so sprechen kann die hat sich
natürlich im Laufe der Zeit geändert
überlegen Sie mal im Jahr 1700 hätten
sie ein Kunstwerk von Andy Warhol
ausgestellt kennen Sie die brilloboxis
wer kennt die brilloboxis ja also das
sind praktisch einfach so so so so
Kartons ja so so Verpackungs Hüllen und
die hat der einfach irgendwie
aufgestapelt und gesagt das ist jetzt
Kunst um 1700 hätte man sie
wahrscheinlich also ich weiß nicht was
aber man hätte sie jedenfalls nicht
Künstler genannt ja
hätte gesagt sie spinnen ja
wahrscheinlich ja um 1700 und sogar noch
um 1900 hätte man das gesagt sie wissen
bestimmt wie damals auf die
Impressionisten reagiert wurde auf die
neue pressionistische Kunst ein Kritiker
hat geschrieben das sind lauter
verrückte und in der Kunst ist eben so
dass da Normativität wenn man so
sprechen kann sehr schnell Wandlung
unterliegt was eben um 1800 schön war
oder als schön galt muss man genauer
sagen das galt eben um 1900 schon nicht
mehr als schön und mit der Mode ist es
genauso das heißt es ist sehr kurzlebig
und vielen Wandlung unterworfen wenn wir
aber von Normativität im starken Sinne
sprechen wollen das heißt nicht nur
bezogen auf bestimmte Zeitalter nicht
nur bezogen auf bestimmte Staaten um
ihre juristischen Gesetze oder
politischen soziologischen Bedingungen
sondern generell für die Menschheit
universell vielleicht sogar für
intelligente Marsianer dann meinen wir
im Folgenden immer die moralische
Normativität darum soll es also auch
heute vor allem gehen und wir können
jetzt hier eben drei Probleme
unterscheiden
und es ist zum Beispiel eine gute Frage
jetzt für den Typ für die Wissensfragen
so eine Frage könnte zum Beispiel in der
Klausur dran kommen und wir werden auch
heute in der zweiten Hälfte der
Vorlesung uns ein paar Klausur Fragen
mal anschauen paar mögliche Klausur
Fragen und die mal gemeinsam lösen dass
sie wissen was auf sie dazu kommt also
wie können wir nochmal Aktivität
begründen das ist das Begründungsproblem
für wie gilt Normativität es ist
geltungsproblem und wie können wir
Normativität erkennen das ist
Erkenntnisproblem die hängt natürlich
alle auf
Ängste miteinander zusammen weil man mit
guten Argument sagen kann Normativität
kann nur für jemanden gelten wenn er
auch den Sinn der Normativität erkennen
kann wenn diese Regel einen völlig
unverständlich sind und so oder sogar
prinzipiell und verständlich sind weil
man einen IQ von 185 braucht um diese
Normativität zu erkennen man aber nur
Nico von 100 hat dann ist es schlecht
und dann macht Normativität keinen Sinn
wir gehen da auch noch genauer drauf
nicht nur für wen es gilt sondern wann
als auch gelten kann so ein Gebot diese
drei Probleme sind sehr sehr zentral
damit will ich nicht sagen dass es noch
andere Probleme geben könnte im Kontext
der Normativität das ist sicherlich
möglich aber die drei möchte ich jetzt
einfach mal besonders hervorheben und
jetzt kann man eben wenn man jetzt uns
den wenn wir uns mal den ersten Problem
jetzt widmen dem Begründungsproblem kann
man
versuchen moralische Normativität wir
gehen jetzt vor allem auf moralischen
Normativität ein dadurch zu begründen
dass man sagt ich beziehe mich hier auf
den
rationalitätsstandard also ich sage über
den Vernunftbegriff kann ich
Normativität moralischen Normativität
begründet mit Bezug auf den Begriff der
vernünftiger Rationalität oder mit Bezug
auf den Begriff universumität oder mit
Bezug auf den welche Autonomie und das
möchte jetzt mal im Folgenden bisschen
genauer erklären man muss man kann jetzt
sagen wir uns auf die Vernunft beziehen
das was vernünftig ist sollte auch getan
werden es ist nicht gut es sollte
verboten sein oder wie auch immer das zu
tun was unvernünftig ist natürlich kann
man sie jetzt wieder fragen was ist denn
jetzt bitteschön vernünftig er hat für
den eines das vernünftig für die andere
ist das vernünftig ja
völlig richtig wenn man dieses Argument
einwirft aber man könnte zumindest jetzt
zum Anfang und Begriff ansetzen man
könnte aber auch das schließt sich jetzt
das ist auch nicht in Konflikt mit dem
Vernunft sagen das was von universalen
Interesse im Interesse ist deshalb auch
getan werden ne also das was eigentlich
jeder will und dann setzt man häufig
dazu sofern er oder sie vernünftig ist
das heißt das sehen Sie schon wieder
universelles Interesse und Vernunft das
hängt ganz eng miteinander zusammen man
kann häufig für Universalität
argumentieren immer dem man sagt das ist
vernünftig und alles andere die Vernunft
die bis in jedem von uns jeder von uns
prinzipiell vernünftig man muss nur bei
klarem Verstand sein und darf nicht der
Willensschwäche unterliegen hat mir
schon oder vielleicht der
Selbsttäuschung aber wenn man rational
ist dann sollte man den Sinn einsehen
und so könnte man eben auch dann
Normalität begründen man kann natürlich
auch noch so argumentieren dass man sagt
wir wir müssen moralische Normativität
oder können Sie dadurch begründen dass
wir sagen nur wenn wir diese Regeln
akzeptieren diese moralischen
Normativität nur dann können wir uns als
wirklich frei oder genau gesagt
Autonomie gewesen denken oder verstehen
wenn wir keinen moralischen Normativität
annehmen dann können wir nicht drei
autonome lesen sein dann geht das nicht
so könnte man auch argumentieren und wir
gehen gleich noch genau auf diese drei
Begründungsversuche Parteien am Beispiel
von bekannt jetzt möchte ich Ihnen noch
mal ein Beispiel bringen aus die
Geschichte der Philosophie wer so
argumentiert hat das war nämlich eben
auch wo so sehen dann sich noch an einem
der ersten Sitzung mache ich auch oben
rechts in den Link rein auf Youtube der
gemein will
im Gegensatz steht zum Wille aller
dieser gemeinwille da könnte wohl so
davon sagen ja der ist vernünftig das
ist eigentlich ein vernünftiger Wille es
ist ein Wille der von universelle
Interesse ist ist ja der gemein will und
nicht nur die Summe der partikularve und
er vergrößert auch die Autonomie genau
das sagt uns so über den Gemeinden will
und dadurch begründet er seine
Normativität man kann natürlich auch wie
man kann das tut sagen wir setzen sowas
wie den kategorischen Imperativ an das
wir unsere Maximen vernünftig
verallgemeinern und dadurch ist autonom
werden das heißt diese drei Strategien
finden wir genauso bei immer man kann
und zu merken zwischen ganzkategorischen
Imperativ und Russos gemeinwille gibt
sehr viele Ähnlichkeiten die
Gemeinsamkeit ist dass hier etwas
verallgemeinert werden soll und zwar
universell der Unterschied ist dass
diese Verallgemeinerung bei Russo
intersubjektiv ist da geht es um ganz
verschiedene Individuen die sich einigen
und bei bekannt ist es nur ein
Individuum das soll ein Individuum sich
intern gewissermaßen einigen nämlich mit
seinen verschiedenen wünschen oder
seinen Maximen da sollen die Maximen
gewissermaßen einen Gemeinden bilden
also das was bei uns so politisch
gedacht wird mit verschiedenen Subjekten
eine Gesellschaft das wird bekannt
bezogen auf eine Person die ihren Willen
intern zu einem Art von gemein bildeten
ganz interessante Beziehung kannt hat
auch wir selbst gesagt hat sehr viel
eurusso zu verdanken gehabt ja in ganz
verschiedenen Hinsicht
kategorischen Imperativ kennen sie
handeln nur nach derjenigen Maxime durch
die du zugleich wollen kannst dass sie
ein allgemeines Gesetz werde da haben
sie jetzt zugleich dieses allgemeine
Gesetz da haben sie dieses universelle
Interesse und sie haben auch so ein
bisschen schon in Gedanken der Autonomie
bei Autonomie bedeutet
Selbstgesetzgebung und die haben das
Gesetz drin gibt noch eine Formel handle
es so dass du die Menschheit sowohl in
deiner Person als in der Person eine
jeden anderen jederzeit zugleich als
Zweck und niemals bloß als Mittel
brauchst auch hier ist der Gedanke der
Verallgemeinerung und zwar so dass die
Verallgemeinerung in der eigenen Person
stattfindet das was berühmte gemeint ist
bekannt dass jenige was in einer Person
stattfindet die Menschheit in der Person
der gemeinwille in mir könnte sein also
versucht hat Normativität
auf moralischer Ebene zu begründen jetzt
machen wir können wir mal hier so eine
kurze diskussionspause machen
und uns noch ein bisschen damit
beschäftigt mit der Frage nach der
Begründung gibt es vielleicht nur andere
Möglichkeiten moralische Normativität zu
begründen das wollen wir jetzt
diskutieren
ja wir haben darüber diskutiert wie man
jetzt absolute moralische Normativität
begründen kann und wir haben
festgestellt aus diesen ganzen Punkten
hier vernünftig universelles Interesse
und wie sie alle heißen Autonomie
gemeinwille da raus absolute moralische
Normativität zu folgen oder abzuleiten
das ist gar nicht so einfach da muss man
schon ziemlich viel Anstrengung
unternehmen und jetzt kommen wir zum
zweiten Problem zum geltungsproblemoral
schon einmal Aktivität also jetzt haben
wir erstmal die Frage diskutiert wie
kann man moralische Normativität
begründen das Begründungsproblem und
jetzt kann man aufs geltungsproblem das
geltungsproblem betrifft die Frage für
wen gilt oder kann oder darf moralischen
Attraktivität überhaupt gelten deswegen
gilt sie und jetzt gibt es verschiedene
Möglichkeiten für alle Menschen für alle
vernünftigen und autonomen Personen oder
auch wenn nicht menschliche Tiere
sie können sich jede mögliche Wesen
vorstellen
gilt es vielleicht auch für Pflanzen
wohl eher nicht aber dann muss man sagen
warum
jedenfalls kann man das jetzt ein
bisschen genau stimmt damit moralischen
Aktivität für einwiesen immer natürlich
auch für kollektive das ist immer ganz
interessant diese Gebote richten sich
natürlich auch an Gruppen kollektive
Personen damit sie gelten kann muss es
dieses Wesen diese erkennen und nachher
handeln können wenn ich den Sinn dieser
Normativität dieses Gebots nicht
einsehen kann
oder wenn ich gar nicht die Kraft habe
diesen Gebot zu folgen
also wenn ich überfordert bin dann kann
dieses Gebot eigentlich nicht für mich
gelten dann bin ich nämlich überfordert
das nennt man auf Englisch
also über
Überforderung
ich gebe mal ein Beispiel
normative Geltung scheint Freiheit und
Autonomie vorauszusetzen kleine Kinder
sind noch nicht deliktsfähig ich glaube
ab einem bestimmten Alter es können
kleine Kinder überhaupt gegen Normen
wirklich juristisch auch verstoßen die
liegtsfähig heißt Sie müssen die
Einsichtsfähigkeit haben in dieses Gebot
zum Beispiel zu juristische Geburt oder
auch moralisch das ist natürlich jetzt
vor allem auf die juristischen Ebene
liegt
strafgesetzbuchen zu lassen
es macht erst Sinn wenn das Wesen von
dem wir sprechen überhaupt den Sinn
einsehen kann
es gibt ein lateinischen Spruch da heißt
ultra posse Nebo obligator niemand wird
über das können hinaus verpflichtet als
über das können ist ultra Pause Demo
niemand obligator wird verpflichtet
haben Sie eine Idee was das bedeutet da
können wir jetzt gleich genauer darüber
diskutieren was bedeutet dieser Spruch
und inwiefern ist es für unser Thema
relevant
ja wir haben darüber diskutiert ob kann
selbst diese These vertritt dass
ich nur dass ich kann weil ich etwas
Zoll und hier kann man natürlich treffen
drüber streiten jedenfalls ist es klar
dass ich etwas erkennen können muss und
danach handeln können muss damit es für
mich Geltung haben kann und zwar
absolute Geld jetzt kommen wir zu
Erkenntnis des greif ich jetzt noch mal
an auf
Erkenntnisproblem wie kann ich jetzt
erkennen was moralisch gilt moralische
Normativität zum Beispiel moralischen
Boote kann dadurch erkannt werden dass
man ihr Gegenteil als vernünftig bzw
logisch widersprüchlich erkennt
ein Beispiel wäre der Maxim Test bei
Manuel kannte
jetzt bin ich ihnen das mal
demonstrieren wie kann das sich denkt
also wie kann jetzt zeigt dass ich
objektiv absolut erkennen kann was von
mir moralisch universal
gefordert wird also bringt es Beispiel
ich habe es mir zu Maxime gemacht mein
Vermögen durch alle sicheren Mittel zu
vergrößern
sichere Mittel heißt wenn ich dadurch
keine Probleme bekomme wenn es halt
irgendwie geht
dann geht es weiter jetzt ist ein
Depositum in meinen Händen dessen
Eigentümer verstorben ist und keine
Handschrift darüber zurückgelassen haben
das ist deswegen wichtig dass die
Eigenschaften verstorben ist und keine
Handschrift darüber zugelassen hat weil
ich jetzt ein sicheres Mittel habe
mein Vermögen zu vergrößern ein sicheres
Mittel heißt mir kann niemand einen
Strick draus drehen weil es ist
nirgendwo vermerkt dass ich das
Depositum habe was ist denn ein
Depositum kommt von lateinisch deponere
heißt einfach abgelegt abgesetzt einfach
eine Leihgabe könnte man sagen ja da
gibt's eine riesen Debatte drüber ähm
also ich würde jetzt mal sagen ein
gleichgegenstand etwas entliehen ist
kann man noch im Detail weiter drüber
sich unterhalten ich habe mir etwas
geliehen und derjenige von dem ich mir
das geliehen habe der hat es nirgends
mehr vermehrt so dass nach seinem toten
niemand weiß dass es eigentlich nicht
mein Gegenstand ist eigentlich der
Gegenstand der verstorbene Person und
laut
üblichen brauch würde nach dem Tod
dieser Person die mir den Gegenstand
verliehen hat eigentlich die
Nachkommenschaft
in Frage kommen als Eigentümerin
und jetzt wende ich erkannt jene Maxime
die Maxime mein Vermögen durch alle
sichere Mitte zu vergrößern auf diesen
gegenwärtigen Fall an dass die Person
die mir die Gegenstand geliehen hat
verstorben ist und ich frage ob sie wohl
die Maxime die Form eines Gesetzes
annehmen mithin ich wohl durch meine
Maxime zugleich ein solches Gesetz geben
könnte das jedermann Abläufen dürfen
dessen Niederlegung ihm niemand beweisen
kann
also das heißt jetzt müssen wir diese
Maxime einfach versuchen zu
verallgemeinern
vernünftig verallgemeinern sprich auf
Widersprüche hin überprüfen
und er sagt jetzt kann jedenfalls ich
werde sofort gewahrt dass ein solches
Prinzip als eine solche Maxime wie er
sie hier vorgestellt hat als Gesetz also
als universal gültig für alle
vernünftigen Wesen gültig sich selbst
vernichten würde als in ein Widerspruch
führen will weil es machen würde das ist
gar kein Depositum gäbe also kann
versucht jetzt hier nicht nur die
erkenntnismoralische Normativität das
sagte hier ich werde gefahren das ist
eine epistemische eine
erkenntnistheoretische Einstellung ich
werde mir dessen bewusst ich erkenne und
zwar sofort erkannt dass das diese
maximum unmoralisches dass diese Maxime
bei dem genommen mit der Normativität
kollidiert das erkenne ich sofort kann
sagt aber noch mehr er sagt sogar auch
ich erkenne es nur nicht nur sondern
eigentlich erkenne ich sogar die
begründungsstruktur also ich kann so
nicht aus der Erkenntnis auch die
begründungsform von moralischer
Normativität ableiten nämlich dass es
sich nicht widersprechen darf das ist
nicht ein Widerspruch führen darf wenn
ich die Maxime vernünftig versuche zu
verallgemeinern und darüber wollen wir
jetzt kurz diskutieren wie sind es zu
verstehen dass es machen würde dass es
gar kein Depositum gäbe ist das ein
Widerspruch der irgendwie Normativität
begründen lässt oder erkennen lässt
diese Frage wollen wir uns jetzt hier
gleich in der Diskussion
widmen
ja das ist eine spannende Diskussion ob
aus diesem Widerspruch wie auch jetzt
genau dieser Widerspruch zu verstehen
ist
inwiefern da jetzt ein eine
Erkenntnismöglichkeit der moralischen
Normativität liegt und vielleicht sogar
auch eine Möglichkeit moralische
Normativität absolut zu begründen folgt
aus diesem Widerspruch wirklich was oder
könnte man sagen da folgt gar nichts
draus riesen Debatte wie immer in der
Philosophie es gebe ich noch kurz ein
Ausblick auf die nächste Vorlesung da
haben wir es zu tun mit dem Problem von
sein also deskriptivität deskriptivität
heißt ich beschreibe etwas ich sage
etwas ist so und so so
und dem sollen das ist die Normativität
wir sind heute schon drauf eingegangen
die Frage die wir uns stellen werden ist
die inwiefern kann es ein Übergang vom
sein also von beschreibenden Sätzen von
Zustände zum sollen geben wie kann ich
das begründen ja oder kann ich das
sollen gar nicht über das sein bestimmen
oder kann es gar kein Übergang vom sein
zum sollen geben wir werden zwei Formen
eines kritischen arguments gegen einen
möglichen Übergang diskutieren von David
Q den haben sie schon kennengelernt der
hatte bestritten dass
Moral normativ oder Vernunft moralisch
sein kann diese Ritz im Finger ja ich
mache oben rechts den Link rein von
David jung werden wir eine Passage Lesen
der sein sollens Fehlschluss und wir
werden von ihm nur das ist einer
zeitgenose von Wittgenstein so im 20
Jahrhundert erste 20 Jahrhundert
ungefähr
im englischen Bereich die ihm nur den
sogenannten naturalistischen Fehlschluss
genau
sie
verläss sie kann man als Fehlschluss
interpretieren kann aber auch anders
interpretieren jedenfalls die Auffassung
dass man gut das Prädikat gut mit
natürlichen Eigenschaften überhaupt mit
Eigenschaften bestimmen kann das werden
wir auch behandeln diese Problematik ja
dann bedanke mich für die Aufmerksamkeit
und wir gehen jetzt hier im Seminar
weiter auf die Übungsaufgaben